hello and welcome to the you're playing
just kit yeah this is one of those guys
we have no squad yeah I don't know why I
don't know how but it's a very bad score
this is one of those guys like playing
quickly I hope for the best probably yes
I i remember i had this stuff against
him gay I am I can check I have to have
to absolutely revamp this line it's just
it's just not good young I mean it's not
good enough to play for anything
anything substantial is the problem
people know notice by now that 94 is the
right move is weird as it looks but it
is right
yeah it's completely symmetrical and it
makes it tough to get anything
substantial out of it
one issue for wide is that the king is
on h1 this is not so great you take a
while to get everything get this get
this into play
my dish is taking taking some time here
okay so 95 is probably yeah it looks
like the relatively best optional cannot
take it yeah that looks okay jack and
night rookie 7 is not actually
threatening that much
hmm
97 does never do an item doesn't do
anything
it's still the relatively best try this
is the prevents that he is just
exchanging group takes rook takes now
would be awkward but I don't have
anything that actually would threaten
the night so we directly attacks this
okay well neither 3d for is something 97
ninety three to four this is actually a
taking the night I'm taking a long time
to understand that very stupid that this
took me so long
and I'm just a taking the noid okay
rookie 7 isn't that just a piece black
resigns oh what a sudden enter that came
Jan so well this is a theoretical line I
mean and it's okay foot like him he
blitz it out like it no no time I don't
know how it continues though so I mean
this is looking quite normal at Bishop
before I think is in precise okay 94 is
actually stronger I mean this is not bad
but 90 force even better if Gerald is
this this then 95 s is the key move
that's very nice night here Black is in
huge trouble so he cannot actually do
that f5 is given by the computer there's
some miracle moves like this and why
does clearly better so be sure before as
a huge mistake and this 94 was a lot
better than this check it here he's
still in the game but f6 is a mistaken
yeah I took me ages to up to play 93
that's really bad that it took so long
yeah if six is a mistake though we
should play Knights is sexist what the
engine is giving a move that I did not
see it all rookie X loop TX be 597 TT
one leads to this ending yeah that's
wrong don't know why stop which gives
white half a point it's just a dead draw
okay so this is what you should have
done and now he's in trouble okay look
the EDD blunders a piece but it's it's
very tough already I think this is what
the engine is giving also just playing a
pawn down yeah it's not this is there's
there are almost no drawing chances I'm
very quick with my king and the pawns
are a very very sound there's no
weakness or whatever that should be a
win for white okay thanks for watching